Now let's look at the another behavior
of mixture model and in this case let's
look at their response to the data
frequencies.
OK, So what you're seeing now is
basically the likelihood function for
the two word document, and we know in
this case the solution is to give text
a probability of 0.9 and the probability
of 0.1.
Now it's interesting to think about a
scenario where we start adding more
words to the document.
So what would happen if we add many
the's to the document?
Now this will change the game, right?
So how? Well, picture
what would the likelihood function look
like now?
It started with the likelihood function
for the two words.
As we add more words, we know that,
we have to just multiply the likelihood
function by additional terms to account
for the additional occurrences of the.
Since in this case all the additional
terms are the, we're going to just
multiply by this term for the
probability of the.
An if we have another occurrence of
the, we multiply again by the same
term and so on, so forth until we add
as many terms as the number of the's
that we added to the document D prime.
Now this obviously changes the
likelihood function, so what's
interesting is now to think about how
would that change our solution.
So what's the optimal solution now?
Intuitively, you would know the
original solution.
0.9 and  0.1 will no longer be optimal
for this new function, right?
But the question is how should we
change it?
Well in general they sum to one.
So in order to change it, we must take
away some probability mess from one
word.
An added the probability mass to the
other word.
The question is which word to have a
reduced the probability and which word to
have a larger probability?
And in particular, let's think about
the probability of the.
Should it be increased to be more than
0.1 or should we decrease it to less
than  0.1?
What do you think?
Now you might want to pause the video
a moment to think more about this
question, because this has to do with
understanding of important behavior of
a mixture model and indeed all the
maximum likelihood estimator.
Now if you look at the formula for a
moment then you will see.
It seems that now the objective
function is more influenced by the than
text before each contributed one turn.
So now, as you can imagine, it would
make sense to actually assign a smaller
probability for text and to make room
for a larger probability for the. Why?
Because the is repeated many times if we
increase it a little bit, it will have
more positive impact, whereas a slight
decrease of text.
We have relatively small impact because
it occurs just once.
Right, so this means there is another
behavior that we observe here that is
high frequency words generally will have high
probabilities from all the
distributions.
And this is no surprise at all, because
after all we are maximizing the
likelihood of the data.
So all the more word occurs, then it's
it makes more sense to give such a word
a high probability because the impact
would be
more on the likelihood function.
This is in fact a very general
phenomenon of all the maximum
likelihood estimator, but in this case
we can see as we see more occurrences
of term.
It also encourages the unknown
distribution theta sub d to assign
somewhat higher probability to this
word.
Now it's also interesting to think
about the impact of probability of
theta sub B.
The probability of choosing one of the
two component models.
Now, we've being so far, assuming that
each model is equally likely and that
gives us 0.5, but you can again look at
this like your function and try to
picture what would happen if we
increase the probability of choosing a
background model.
Now you will see these terms for
the will have a different form where the
probability of 'the' would be even
larger because the background that has a
high probability for the word and the
coefficient
in front of 0.9 which is now 0.5
would be even larger. When this is
larger the overall result would be
larger and that also makes them less
important for theta sub D to increase
the probability for the because
it's already very large so the impact
here of increasing the probability of
the is somewhat regulated by this
coefficient 0.5.
If it's a larger on the background then
it becomes less important to increase
the value so.
So.
This means the behavior here, which is
high frequency words tend to get
higher probabilities are affected or
regularised somewhat by the
probability of choosing each component.
The more likely a component that is
being chosen, it's more important than
to have higher values for these
frequent words.
If you have a very small probability of
being chosen, than the incentive is
less.
So to summarize, we have just discussed
the mixture model and we discussed the
estimation problem of mixture model and
in particular we discussed some general
behavior of the estimate an that means
we can expect the our estimator to
capture these intuitions.
1st Every component component model
attempts to assign high probabilities
to high frequency words in the data.
And this is to collaboratively
maximize likelihood.
Second, different component models tend
to bet high probabilities on
different words, and this is to avoid
competition or waste of probability,
and this would allow them to
collaborate more efficiently to
maximize the likelihood.
3rd, the probability of choosing each
component
regulates the collaboration and
competition between the component
models.
It would allow some component models to
respond more to the change, for example
of frequency of data point in the data.
We also talk about the special case of
fixing one component to a background word
distribution, and this distribution can
be estimated by using a collection of
documents.
A large collection of English
documents,
by using just one distribution and then
we'll just have normalized frequencies
of terms to give us the probabilities
of all these words.
Now when we use such a specialized
mixture model, we show that we can
effectively get rid of background words
in the other component.
And that would make the discovered
topic more discriminative.
This is also an example of imposing a
prior on the model parameters and the
prior
here basically means one model must be
exactly the same as the background
language model, and if you recall what
we talked about in Bayesian estimation
and this prior would allow us to favor
a model that's consistent with our
prior.
In fact, if it's not consistent,
we're going to say the model is
impossible, so it has a zero prior
probability, and that effectively
excludes
such a scenario.
This is also an issue that we will talk more
later.